KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
Joining me in the
studio right now
is Andrew from Structur3D
Printing in Canada.
Andrew, how are you?
ANDREW FINKLE: Good.
How are you?
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
Thank you for joining
us in the studio.
ANDREW FINKLE: Awesome.
Thanks for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah, no worries.
So tell us a little bit
about Structur3D Printing.
ANDREW FINKLE: OK.
Structur3D Printing is looking
to solve the problem right now
in 3D printing, which is
the limitation of materials.
So, traditionally,
3D printing has
been kind of like a
mechanized hot glue gun.
So it'll take a hard
plastic, melt it down,
and build something up.
What we've created
is this new tool head
that will allow printing
with materials way
beyond just plastic.
So we can print very
strong, flexible materials.
We work with a lot of different
biomaterials and research
groups.
So we're enabling the physical
developers of the world
to design and prototype
with many more of the things
that they're familiar
with in a day-to-day life.
KORY JEFFREY: Cool.
So what are some of
the things-- like what
are some of the materials?
You've obviously
brought some stuff here.
ANDREW FINKLE: Right.
So some of the ones
I've brought here
are the fun-- so
these are silicones.
So what kind of advantage
or different applications
this brings to the table is
the flexibility and durability.
So one example is wearable
tech-type devices can now
be prototyped using our device.
Things like a Fitbit,
a lot of people
have trouble finding the
right kind of texture.
That's something that we can
help them get to that stage.
A couple other big areas for
us are printing with foods.
So food science
is really growing.
And we're able to enable the
creation of a lot of new,
I guess, textures and
ways to make food.
So on the easy
end, it's something
like printing a cake
topper for your birthday
that's personalized.
It says, Happy Birthday Kory.
And then on the high end,
there are research groups
around the world who are
growing meat in a lab,
and we're able to help them take
this meat that they've grown
and print the steak.
KORY JEFFREY: That's
actually really cool.
That's cool.
So what is the craziest
thing that you've
seen somebody print
with your machine
so far that you're aware of?
ANDREW FINKLE: I guess it's
not the craziest material,
but the best thing I've seen
just in the last week or so
is one of our
Kickstarter backers,
one of our early customers,
prints with his daughter
in clay and ceramics.
And he creates his kids'
toys with his daughter.
They design it on the
computer in the CAD software.
And he'll print out the
toys, and the daughter
will paint them and create them.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
ANDREW FINKLE: Yeah,
it's really cool.
We're trying right now to
partner with a company that
is growing shark fin meat,
trying to save endangered
species by creating a
different channel for people
to get this delicacy.
And we're kind of the last step
that helps create the textures,
create the densities, make
it actually not just taste,
but feel like the natural thing.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
So you mentioned you've
run a Kickstarter.
ANDREW FINKLE: We have.
KORY JEFFREY: So you've
sold a bunch of things.
What stage are you at now?
What are you doing today?
ANDREW FINKLE: So we're
actually in an accelerator
down here in San Francisco.
We are focusing on
taking our company
to the next step, so figuring
out some different channels
and partners to work with
and really refining how--
or what we've learned
through the Kickstarter.
So we had a wide
variety of customers
through the Kickstarter.
And we found out where our
device is providing the most
value, and we're starting
to focus in on that.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
Obviously, you're at an
accelerator in the Valley.
You're here at
Founder World today.
What attracted
you to this event?
ANDREW FINKLE: So we,
coming from Canada,
kind of had a
limited view of how
the startup world and the whole
tech ecosystem worked here.
So that is a big part
of why we're here,
is getting to know other
companies, talking to people,
really calibrating
ourselves with how things
are working in the Valley.
KORY JEFFREY: Nice.
As you look around here, you're
one of the demonstrators,
obviously.
But other than 3D printing,
are there other technologies,
either here or otherwise, that
really kind of excite you guys?
ANDREW FINKLE: Oh,
interesting question.
I know for me-- so my
background is in nanotechnology.
So I've seen a lot of what is
to come in different industries.
And what is really
fascinating, being down here,
is I'm seeing them
come to market now.
It's no longer just
stuff I saw in a textbook
and thought, oh,
this is really cool.
It's actually happening.
And that includes
things like growing meat
or different interfacing
with the human body
so that you could
create robotic arms that
are controlled by the brain.
And it's just in the
digital fabrication space.
So outside of 3D
printing, there are a lot
of really cool technologies.
There is a 3D
printing company that
is creating life-sized 3D
printing sculptures out of wood
and leather and
things like that.
They just launched on
crowdfunding a few days ago
and have already raised
over $30 million.
They just ousted
Pebble as the leader.
And so there's a lot of energy
and a lot of resources going
into new ways to make things.
And that's one thing that
I'm really fascinated with.
KORY JEFFREY: So on that vein,
do you have a favorite Google
technology?
ANDREW FINKLE: So I
think one thing that's
really interesting me is Google
is getting into the 3D printing
space.
I can't remember the name
of the company they just
invested heavily in.
But they're pushing a new
way of 3D printing, which
is almost like printing
with holographs,
which is really cool.
It really allows for
this mass customization
of products moving forward.
And then, outside of
that, I think my favorite
is my Android phone.
KORY JEFFREY: Yes!
ANDREW FINKLE: Yeah, I
used to be an Apple fanboy
and completely converted, and
I'm addicted to my phone now.
KORY JEFFREY: Well,
welcome to the team.
ANDREW FINKLE: Awesome.
Thanks for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
Andrew, thanks so
much for joining me.
ANDREW FINKLE: Thanks again.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah, no worries.
And thank you guys
for joining us.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]